[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24
más romeros a la conmigo en el estudio
mar muy buena mañana del lunes hoy se
cumplen 10 años desde que se anunció al
mundo el bosón de higgs buenos días
efectivamente nos alejamos un poquito de
la salud pero nos quedamos en el mundo
científico para hacer esta excepción y
hablar de uno de los descubrimientos más
importantes del siglo 21 y de hecho una
de las noticias que probablemente más
emoción generó en el mundo sin que nadie
supiera tanto lo que estábamos hablando
y vamos a hacer un intento de explicarlo
estamos hablando del 4 de julio de 2012
en ginebra en la sede del cern que es el
centro europeo para la investigación
nuclear donde se culminó con décadas y
décadas de investigación para encontrar
esta esquiva partícula elemental este
bosón de higgs que de hecho ya se había
teorizado en
1964 por peter higgs que le da su nombre
y otros grupos de científicos pero que
finalmente dio ese salto de la teoría a
la práctica gracias al súper al
acelerador de partículas que también
estaban viendo ahora en las imágenes
había mucha expectativa mundial porque
también llevaban años pues investigando
600 experimentos este es el momento en
el que están presentando los resultados
de esa investigación y también van a ver
de hecho a peter higgs que se seca los
ojos con un pañuelo porque bueno él es
un hombre de más de 80 años en este
momento al año siguiente recibió el
premio nobel y creía pues realmente que
nunca iba a haber demostrado en la
práctica eso que él había imaginado y
que había teorizado décadas antes bueno
y qué es eso que es el bosón de higgs
bueno lo apodan la partícula de dios
pero aunque eso al final es un nombre
más comercial otra cosa es una partícula
elemental en lo que se conoce partículas
elementales en la física es básicamente
todo eso que es tan pequeño que ya no se
puede dividir más son las primeras
partículas que existen desde el inicio
del universo y cuyas interacciones han
creado el mundo tal y como lo conocemos
hoy en día hay dos tipos de partículas
por un lado los fermines que son lo que
constituye la materia es lo que hace que
exista pues esta mesa que existamos
nosotros las estrellas la cerveza todo
lo que te puedas imaginar un ejemplo por
ejemplo los electrones que es una de las
partículas que forman los átomos los
otros son los bosones en este caso como
el bosón de higgs que son responsables
de las fuerzas fundamentales estamos
hablando por ejemplo de fuerzas como
esas interacciones entre una partícula y
otra el electromagnetismo las fuerzas
nucleares y el bosón es uno de estos
tipos de partículas porque es importante
pues porque es el elemento que faltaba
la pieza clave que faltaba para
demostrar o terminar de cuajar lo que se
conoce como el modelo estándar en la
física que diríamos que es como como la
tabla periódica para la química pues
para la física no todo eso que define
cómo entendemos hoy en día el mundo
desde la perspectiva física desde el
universo y faltaba esta cosa y es
precisamente la explicación de por qué
las mate las partículas perdón tienen
masa son tan pequeñas que es casi cero
pero no es cero tienen masa las
partículas de estas y a raíz de que las
partículas tengan masa explica que todo
lo demás también de nuevo todos estos
elementos que pasa que con este bosón de
higgs tiene un campo asociado que nos lo
podemos imaginar como si fuera
el espacio que hay entre las partículas
en vez de estar vacío tiene como un
océano como una tela incluso como una
especie de materia de este campo
asociado de hicks y como que tan fácil o
qué tan difícil o cómo atraviesen las
partículas de esta materia o este océano
qué tan fácil es qué tan difícil es qué
tan rápido cuanto sobre todo se agrupa a
su alrededor es lo que le confiere esa
masa entonces pues así explicado
intentamos que sea sencillo pero
básicamente es se resuelve el misterio
de por qué las cosas tienen masa gracias
a este bosón y para esto descubrió en
tomar fue indispensable el conocido
acelerador de partículas porque así es
es también esas imágenes que estábamos
viendo al inicio es una construcción
faraónica raúl es cerca de la frontera
de la frontera entre francia y suiza es
un túnel de 27 kilómetros de largo
excavado 100 metros bajo tierra hecho en
2008 para que nos hagamos una idea ocupa
más o menos el mismo tamaño que una
ciudad mediana pequeña santa marta por
ejemplo en colombia rosario por ejemplo
en argentina todo eso es este súper
acelerador y la instalación que lo
permiten básicamente en este túnel se
proyectan dos rayos de protones o de
hadrones que son composiciones de
distintos tipos de estas partículas que
estábamos explicando previamente casi a
la velocidad de la luz también gracias a
unos
imanes muy potentes y aceleradores que
van a lo largo de todo este túnel y
básicamente lo que hacen es ver qué pasa
cuando chocan giorno permite recrear
como condiciones relativamente parecidas
a las del inicio del universo que
estábamos explicando y permite
comprender pues su
comportamiento en estos momentos además
del bosón de higgs que otros hallazgos
han salido de este acelerador que
estábamos viendo a más enorme exacto es
una construcción absurda muy difícil de
imaginar bueno descubrimientos tan
importantes como este bosón la verdad
todavía no ha habido ninguno y de hecho
es algo que a veces se puede hasta
llegar a criticar no porque se hizo toda
esta contradicción tan grande con
resultados tan poco claros pero la
verdad es que es muy interesante también
reconocer que también vale la pena
depende de cómo no hacer estas
construcciones de hacer estas
inversiones a veces sin un desenlace
cierto tampoco sin saber qué es lo que
va a pasar pero a veces pues como pasó
con el bosón hace diez años da sus
frutos creen que van a descubrir nuevas
partículas descubrir otras teorías o
probar otras teorías físicas pero bueno
digamos que a veces las cosas no tienen
una utilidad de tanquear a más allá de
descubrir por ejemplo por qué las cosas
tienen materia quiera armar y además
cómo es la ciencia por ahora no lo
sabemos pero seguramente muchísimo más
adelante no sé si nosotros estaremos
unidos pero seguramente arrojaría otro
hallazgo quién sabe dentro de un tiempo
quizás estamos haciendo la noticia de
hace diez años descubrimos otra teoría
no vamos a ver gracias mar como siempre
por toda la información de salud en esta
oportunidad de ciencia nosotros vamos a
pasar a saludar a nuestra segunda
invitada al día